ouh là là mais je vois des gens qui
dorment beaucoup trop bien ici en ce
moment il faut qu'on leur fasse pas un
petit peu là les amis que menteur il
vous moi ça va j'ai découvert pendant
mes vacances l'existence d'une chaîne
youtube extrêmement creepy et écoutez
moi bien
j'ai regardé toutes les vidéos de cette
chaîne et [ __ ] je suis pas bien du
tout bien évidemment comme tout le monde
quand je découvre une chaîne youtube je
commence par lire la description de
cette dernière
c'est faux rcsa mais moi je les fais là
est mon nom et d ibra on et moi où je
viens juste de comprendre que je peux
faire mon propre compte youtube
je pensais pas que les gens normaux
pouvait en ferrain je croyais que
c'était réservé aux célébrités qui avait
des caméras qui coûte cher en attendant
un bon coup quoi la débrouille merci de
regarder mes vidéos et j'espère que vous
voudrez bien être ami avec mouawad ordre
la chaîne a été créée le 27 juin 2017
qui à cette période ne savais pas que
tout le monde pouvait mais des vidéos
sur youtube station traquenard on est
d'accord alors qu'est ce que j'ai fait
après ça je suis allé voir la première
vidéo daisy brown s'est pas du tout ce
que j'imaginais bordel de merde et
unique procès ce qui a compromis la
description de sa chaîne youtube c'est
que la petit résumé elle s'occupe d'un
petit monstre qui s'appelle halal et qui
se nourrit uniquement de sucre et d'où
elle a découvert la première fois en
allant dans sa cuisine il était là et
ils étaient beaucoup plus petit qu
actuellement il a bien grandi entre
temps elle a d'abord eu très peur puis
son père lui a expliqué que tout allait
bien qu'il n'y avait rien de grave rien
dangereux ans qui travaillait simplement
sur la création d'une autre forme de vie
et qu'elles n'avaient rien à craindre
des mecs t bag un des trucs alors
parlons de son père à daisy c'est quoi
ce bordel là dans cette famille c'est un
scientifique qui est plutôt intelligent
puisque c'est lui qui a créé à l'âne et
vous l'aurez compris il travaille dans
la génétique est dans l'adn
on apprendra que daisy est jamais allé à
son laboratoire à tel point qu'elle sait
même pas où il est on sait que c'est
là-bas que son père a créé à l'âme après
cette vidéo daisy mais une vidéo de l
eau so tout simplement pas d'histoire de
monstres une vidéo parfaitement normal
que n'importe qui pourrait sortir on
passe maintenant à la troisième vidéo
qui est horrible
il s'agit d'une vidéo dans laquelle
pendant qu'elle donne de l'eau sucrée
alan kay le nourrit elle nous parle un
petit peu de son père dont elle donne
les infos que je vous ai dit juste avant
sa scientifique externe
elle va ensuite on est un peu plus
d'infos autour de à l'année d'elle et de
son père et de sa maison parce que suite
à la première vidéo il ya pas mal de
gens qui sont dit mais purée il faut que
tu en sache plus sur ce petit monde pour
bientôt occupée pour pas le mettre en
danger
bonjour et buts et le monstre des gens
lui avait alors conseillé d'aller dans
le sous sol de sa maison pour peut-être
trouvé des notes que son père aurait
laissé pour en savoir un peu plus sur
bas cette créature qui a créé son père
homme d'avoir une pièce comme ça chez
soit fermée depuis qu'on a deux ans
ouais c'est vrai ça doit être pour ça
assez dangereux la moisissure elle va
terminer la vidéo avec un air un peu
saoulé parce qu'il ya pas mal de gens
qui lui disait il est où ton père il est
où ton père comme ses deux créateurs
d'alan forcément tout le monde a envie
de le voir et elle dit qu'elle sait pas
où il et elle a l'air très blasé en
attendant est-ce qu'on peut revenir un
peu en arrière dans la vidéo on a ce
qu'elle ressent à travers les sous
titres de youtube
ok c'est un peu chelou et moi on s'est
un peu mieux ce qu'elle ressent mais
c'est un peu chelou quand même on passe
à la suite alors qu'est-ce qu'on peut
faire comme vidéo sur youtube comme on
s'occupe à plein temps d'un petit
monstre
en inculpant elle va le maquiller [ __ ]
de sa mère dans toutes les vidéos fard à
paupières rouge à lèvres même pas au bon
endroit puisque elle le met sur son
ventre la vidéo suivante se passe sans
alan puisqu'on voit daisy dans son
grenier en train de chercher les
fameuses notes de son père qui pourrait
en apprendre plus sur allan et lui
permettre de s'occuper au mieux de lui
pour sa cinquième vidéo elle se creuse
la tête daisy elle se dit aujourd'hui on
va faire un procès est un peu plus
poussé avec mon monstre
dans ce monde je crois que tout le monde
a la même puisqu'elle est tout le monde
à un monstre elle s'éteint même que des
gens aient jamais fait de vidéos make up
sur leurs monstres avant elle est
complètement dans sa bulle dans cette
vidéo elle va donner plusieurs sucre à
alan mais à un moment donné il ya les
fameux sutil dont je vous ai parlé qui
reviennent sauf que cette fois j'ai pas
l'impression que ça décrypte ce que
ressent daisy
[Musique]
et ça annonce un peu la couleur de ce
qui va suivre
elle ensuite refaire une vidéo elle
parle de ses flops ce sera ma passion
est juste derrière elle va faire une
autre vidéo avec malades
la vidéo s'appelle alan grandi et daisy
va expliquer qu'il ya des taches bleues
qui commencent à apparaître sur son
corps et nous laisse ma crainte c'est
quoi ça deux semaines plus tard nouvelle
vidéo sur la chaîne de daisy qui
s'appelle alan m'a arraché les cheveux
elle nourrit des sucres et arrache les
cheveux
j'espère que c'est pas pareil avec les
bébés humains sinon je serais jamais
d'enfant mois une fois de plus il ya
quelques sous titres à la fin de cette
vidéo qui nous montre que d'essayer
désespérée elle va dire je peux pas y
arriver seul s'il te plaît reviens elle
parle probablement de son père même s'il
a jamais dit qu'il était plus là et on
se doute que pour la suite elle va
galérer sa mère encore plus mes skis ça
part en vrille
on va ensuite avoir un mois et demi sans
nouvelles dahlan et daisy on espère
qu'il n'a pas bouffer et la pouf
nouvelle vidéo justin kockott et qui
s'est fait quoi bordel il ya une plus
basse dans la nuque c'est pas arrivé par
hasard qu'ils gagnent be fine à
danneberg green et
et
attends à la fête maintenant ça suffit
ici on comprend clairement gala en a
marre de la situation qu'il a hâte
d'être autonome de pouvoir marcher de
pouvoir [ __ ]
daisy au vide ordure il se rassure en se
disant que c'est pas grave ce qui lui
arrive pas ce qui grandit et on aimerait
qu'ils arrêtent un peu de grandir parce
que il commença avant dépenser un peu
machiavélique ce connard de man après
quelques vidéos qui ça va un peu à rien
d'aisé mais une vidéo en ligne qui fait
un peu froid dans doa pas se mentir
parce que elle a grandi manmohan singh
[ __ ] mais d ici mais tu as titus au
dessus un moment à quel moment quand on
grandit on a une sorte de petit arbres
d'une forêt maléfique sur la hanche l'a
hélas poschiavo à tête on en parle ou
pas j'ai envie de taper tué qu'un
marteau mon gars deux semaines plus tard
nouvelle vidéo et là on commence à se
dire mais pourquoi t'as pas jeter ce
monde bordage me répète mais c'est
horrible daisy fait une vidéo est jean
ladent aussi le dessin c'est l'une de
ses passions et on entend à un enfant
qui fait beaucoup de bruit un peu chiant
au bout d'un moment elle va le voir elle
le surprend avec des feuilles dans la
bouche
alors elle s'inquiète pour sa santé et
pas pour sa vie à elle et lui retire le
papier de la bouche et elle découvre sur
le papier des dessins que elle elle n'a
jamais fait il est capable de dessiner
le cours s'est terminée va lui mettre
des stylos dans les yeux elle va mourir
c'est sûr là on est clairement au summum
de l'inquiétude et pour couronner le
tout qu'est ce qui se passe bas débit et
décide de ne plus rien mettre en ligne
pendant deux mois
merci d ici bonne idée ça nous rassure
c'est gentil deux mois plus tard
nouvelle vidéo intitulée nous sommes de
retour
c'est quoi ça a l'air à petit ses yeux
des yeux ou quoi
non pas que l'hôte est capable de tignes
en caméra
[Musique]
[ __ ] de merde
alan se met à faire des progrès sur
youtube com ibra mais qu'est-ce qui se
passe
et surtout il est assez grand pour
ramper et tenir la caméra mais qu'il
faut qu'il finisse sa croissance un jour
parce que ça commence à devenir
dangereux en fait la faire après cette
petite points qui méritent un pouce leur
appartement turp la vidéo parents faisca
moody's explique pourquoi elle a fait
une pause aussi longue sur youtube etc
et puis à la fin de la vidéo c'est un
rush de l qui examine alan pendant qu'il
dort et là dans les sous-titrés fameux
sous titre c'est une sorte de flash back
d'une discussion entre son père et un
inconnu
on va appeler michel et michel explique
à curtis le père de daisy que ce qu'il
fait c'est très mal que ça le rend
dingue qui s'en rendent pas compte
curtis répondent insistant sur le fait
qu' à aucun mal à faire ce qu'il fait
qui a tout à fait le droit et la
conversation va se terminer par michel
qui menacent d'appeler les services
sociaux parce qu'il a peur tout scène
conséquences très négatives sur la fille
de curtis donc d ici on passe à un mois
plus tard on fait comme ça allait on
fait comme ça on regarde tout de suite
qu'elle a mis en ligne des idées à faire
une vidéo dans laquelle elle annonce
avoir enfin trouvé les fameuses
cassettes les notes de son père et
j'avoue rester bien cachés puisqu'elle
était dans un petit placard de merde
[ __ ] tu vas voir greneta vais pas
regarder dans un petit placard de merde
de ton salon commencent à préférer alan
la dei explique avoir trouvé des
affaires de son père et plus
particulièrement le truc qui attire le
plus l'attention dans ces dernières
c'est une cassette que son père a laissé
avec marc et oddo daisy s'il te plaît
écoute daisy va alors mettre la cassette
et là c'est hyper cool parce qu'on
apprend beaucoup de choses sur son père
et donc sur allan donc sur le fond de
cette histoire parce que là on comprend
toujours pas d'où vient la ne comprends
pas pourquoi c'est lui qui s'en occupe
on comprend pas pourquoi on voit jamais
son père on comprend que dalle son père
commence par direct lui dire qu'il va
plus faire partie de sa vie et que ça va
être difficile pour elle de comprendre
il va ensuite s'excuser d'avoir
travaillé pendant des années sur ces
fameuses expérience d'avoir cherché à
créer quelque chose qui lui apporte
bonheur et l'épanouissement alors qu'il
avait désiré juste à côté de lui et que
ça aurait dû suffire en fait c'est sa
fille il va terminer son discours en
disant que rose serait fier de daisy est
que plus des irrigants déplu à lui
ressent on suppose donc que rose et la
mère de djezzy la fin de la vidéo est
très glauque puisque daisy va chercher
un plaid et s'allonge par terre et
elle va mettre en boucle le moment où
son père lui dit qu'il aime on se doute
à partir de là que ça fait un moment
qu'elle n'a pas vu son père une semaine
après des ipos ta vidéo la plus mignonne
de la chaîne puisqu'elle nous présente
un chat si tu voulais quitter l'île
[Musique]
oui ça change de ce groupe d que dahlan
elle explique que le ch à rodez dans le
fronton chez elle donc elle l'a fait
rentrer qu'elle a un collier sur lequel
il a marqué son nom donc ce chat
s'appelle straub et on espère qu'à la
n'aura pas le sommes au point de nom
[Musique]
strawberry était très très vieille et
bornes vieillesse une semaine après
wisques à l'asnl a dézingué deux
semaines plus tard nouvelle vidéo désiré
les embête âge de cablanc craquage
psychologique total allongé dans un amas
de débris et dans les fameux sous titres
on découvre un flashback d'une
conversation entre allan et daisy dans
lequel alan dit que son père pouvait que
daisy était complètement diabolique
c'est elle qui a tuer rose sa maman
grâce à ce moment là on peut comprendre
toute l'histoire de daisy et curtis le
père de désir rose est probablement mort
très peu de temps après avoir mis au
monde des ssii curtis ayant un chagrin
immense et mis en quête de peut-être la
ramener à la vie ou de créer quelque
chose pour compenser le manque de rose
sa femme et ça a donné à l'âme
un mois après son pétage de câble
nouvelle vidéo sur la chaîne 2 days et
le début nous montons direct que c'est
pas de vidéo comme les autres à temps
mais pourquoi j'appelle cette croissance
mois de malades là je suis la même
taille que j'ai 14 ans et lui sa tête et
à coups de pieds de volume en un mois
ouais je m'énerve je m'applique un peu
trop
[Musique]
il y en a poussé dans le fameux sous sol
le sous sol dans lequel elle n'est
jamais allée dans lequel on ne sait pas
ce qu'il y a
[Musique]
[Rires]
non non on n'a pas besoin d'un deuxième
à la mère de jardin pedja ça suffisait
bon alan d'eux qu'ils appellent l'eeetop
qui est un nom de plantes explique rdx
son père qui l'a fabriqué en mélangeant
justement de l'adn de leigh top et de
l'adn humain décisive alors retirer le
masque de l'eee top et alors est claire
on va du passage bon il ya un peu du
positif ont des coûts qui n'a pas eu la
langue comme expérience et peut-être
qu'elles n'ont pas tout donné
personne horrible comme malade peut-être
y en a même qui ont pouvoir et des
désirs ou alors elle est dans la merde
avec l'amour dernière vidéo de la chaîne
au moi je fais cette vidéo elle a été
mise en ligne il ya trois jours et
j'attendais qu'il y ait justement cette
vidéo là parce qu'elle met fin à toute
l'histoire et c'est un peu triste
d'ailleurs ce qui se passe la vidéo
commence par daisy qui fait ses affaires
elle a l'air d'avoir enfin compris
quelle année dangereux et qu'elle doit
se marrer l ami l'eeetop dans ces
affaires elle a l'air de vouloir nagui
top avec et tout se passe bien jusqu'à
ce qu'elle prenne la cassette de son
père pour l'emmener probablement écouter
le passage ou ludiques qui l'aiment
parce qu'il ne reste plus que ça de son
père
green
le vigan
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
[ __ ] ça fait six mois qu'on attend ça
on sent qu'elle est triste de l'avoir
tué parce que c'était un peu la création
de son père mais d'un autre côté elle
allie top qui est aussi une création de
son père et qui a l'air un peu plus
bienveillants alors elle va ensuite
prendre ses affaires y compris les tops
et partir loin et on suppose qu'il y
aura peut-être une saison 2 où c'est
l'histoire de l élite
j'espère en tout cas c'est la fin de
cette vidéo les avis j'espère que vous a
plu et ces cas n'hésitez pas allez
m'aider lebron la personne qui est
derrière ce conte elle a fait un travail
de dingue c'est hyper malin d'avoir créé
une sorte de personnes qui renfermée sur
elle même et il ya un petit truc bizarre
autour de son père et c'est une nouvelle
manière aussi de raconter ça de faire
genre qu'elle est youtube us et qu'elle
a juste une vie pas très normal mais
elle croit que c'est normal j'ai pas
j'ai adoré cette idée là de transmettre
une histoire à travers ça voilà tout ça
pour vous dire que j'ai trouvé ça génial
et je voulais absolument en parler
décortiquer un peu toute cette histoire
de daisy brand hollywood vous pouvez
lâché d'études à cette personne comme ça
peut faire un truc cool c'est bien parce
que là quand tu vois les les jambes de
alan quand il arrive à être debout et
c'est vraiment des gens qui m'aiment
peinte en bleu on comprend que quelques
difficultés à financer le projet mais
franchement charron le truc charmant
justement c'est vraiment quelqu'un qui a
bu raconte un truc avec aucun moyen qui
s'était chier nombre à volants bisous à
vous à bientôt dans une prochaine vidéo
au revoir bonne nuit et attention j'ai
cru voir aaland sous votre lit
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]